es hora de pasar a las noticias
económicas con Daniel hablandon Daniela
Buenos días para usted Hola Ángela
Buenos días vamos a empezar hablando de
los estudiantes en Estados Unidos están
en vilo por la condonación de sus
préstamos Cómo es la historia pues mire
una de las principales promesas de
campaña de Joe biden fue perdonarles los
créditos federales a millones de
estudiantes Sin embargo a comienzos de
esta semana los jueces de la Corte
Suprema que son la mayoría nominados por
el partido republicano de oposición
escucharon los argumentos de la casa
blanca y algunos de ellos cuestionaron
Si en realidad Esta sí tiene la
autoridad para condonar estos de estas
deudas o se está extralimitando en sus
funciones un reportero le preguntó al
presidente Joe biden sobre el tema y
esto respondió escuetamente
Confío en que estamos del lado correcto
de la ley todavía no estoy seguro del
resultado de la decisión
vamos a ver a Daniela En qué consiste
este plan con este discurso pues tan
común en los demócratas no Sí señora
pues este plan anunciado en agosto
cancelaría Diez mil dólares en deuda
Federal para aquellos que ganan menos de
125 mil dólares al año u hogares con
menos de 250 mil dólares en ingresos
Pero hay quienes inclusive pueden
aplicar para una condonación de hasta 20
mil dólares de todos pero de maneras
este programa está dirigido a unos 43
millones de estudiantes como lo vemos
acá de los cuales 26 millones ya
radicaron solicitudes y de ese total a
16 millones ya les han sido aprobadas
sin embargo ya ha habido sentencias
judiciales que tienen este alivio en
suspenso inclusive el departamento de
Educación dejó de aceptar solicitudes En
noviembre Por esos desafíos legales la
última palabra la tiene el alto tribunal
pero es posible que esto no ocurra antes
de junio de este año no yo también
estaría comiéndome las uñas Sí señor
Daniela la cadena de café más grande del
mundo fue castigada por intentar impedir
la formación de sindicatos
Bueno un tribunal laboral Federal de
Estados Unidos le ordenó a Starbucks que
reincorpore a siete trabajadores
despedidos también que reabra un local
que había sido cerrado y que publique un
aviso de 13 páginas en el que enumere
sus violaciones laborales y de los
derechos de los trabajadores en todas
las tiendas un juez de la junta Nacional
de relaciones laborales descubrió que el
año pasado esta empresa violó las leyes
cientos de veces durante una campaña de
sindicalización en Buffalo Nueva York de
la que hablamos acá previamente el año
pasado concretamente dice que la empresa
amenazó a sus empleados los espió e
inclusive aplicó estrictamente para los
códigos de vestimenta y otras políticas
a quienes promovieron la creación del
sindicato este aviso esto es bien
particular lo debe leer el propio de la
empresa o en su defecto les debe
distribuir una grabación a todos los
empleados Aunque Starbucks dice que va a
apelar esta decisión pues que le parece
Pues que es injusta
y en otros temas el gobierno de Colombia
inició una investigación oficial contra
viva era este drama de la aerolínea de
bajo costo que hemos venido contando
aquí en France 24 Pues el Ministerio de
transporte ha dicho que la empresa no
tenía justificación para la interrupción
súbita de sus operaciones el lunes por
la noche dejando a miles de pasajeros
varados en aeropuertos no solamente de
Colombia como lo veníamos diciendo acá
sino también de otros países de la
región Aunque la situación ya está
volviendo a la normalidad porque Los
viajeros están utilizando otros
aerolíneas sin costo adicional para ir a
sus destinos ahora el ojo está puesto
sobre la compañía pues no les cumplió a
los usuarios que ya tenían reservas
emitidas y confirmadas una orden
administrativa para que dé cumplimiento
a las obligaciones que genera el
contrato de transporte en el marco de la
protección de los derechos de los
usuarios para lo cual les dio tres días
para que cumpla de igual manera la
aerocivil continuará su proceso de
revisión de la integración
solicitada por las aerolíneas Avianca y
viva dentro del debido proceso
administrativo y con una propuesta Clara
de protección a los usuarios del
transporte aéreo y a los más de 1700
trabajadores de la aerolínea viva aquí
se ha hablado mucho de chantaje de viva
Air no Sí para que le dejen que a Bianca
lo compré bueno y vamos a otra noticia
en Líbano se está comenzando a ver una
dolarización de facto desde hace varios
meses Pero a partir de hoy y de manera
indefinida El Banco Central del Líbano
va a vender dólares a una tasa de 70.000
libras por unidad esos son 20 mil libras
menos de la cifra histórica de 90.000
que cuesta en el mercado informal es
decir se están están llegando a un punto
en común y casi el doble de lo que se
viene vendiendo la moneda estadounidense
en este país
en crisis Esta es una estrategia para
tratar de reevaluar artificialmente la
moneda que ha perdido más del 95% de su
valor desde que comenzó el colapso
económico en 2019 veamos el informe
dólar estable o libre libanesa
fluctuante Esto es lo que tienen que
decidir los compradores locales a la
hora de ir al supermercado desde 2019
Líbano se ha visto sumido en una
dramática crisis económica que ha hecho
que el valor de la moneda local la libra
libanesa caiga en picada debido a su
valor inestable el precio del dólar
supone un alivio para algunos ciudadanos
libaneses para mí es mejor que los
precios se fijen en dólares así los
supermercados no cambian los precios
todos los días si un producto tiene un
precio de 2 dólares estadounidenses
podemos estar seguros de que se
mantendrá igual y no subirán y bajará el
precio de un día para otro fijar los
precios en dólares estadounidenses es
mejor
sin embargo para otros Este cambio
supone una dificultad en su vida
cotidiana me sorprendió ver que todos se
cotizaba en dólares estadounidenses no
encontraba nada en libres libanesas
ahora tengo que calcular los precios una
molestia para los ciudadanos en febrero
el ministro de economía a misa Lama
anunció que supermercados podrían
empezar a fijar los precios de los
productos en dólares mientras que los
compradores podrían elegir la moneda que
deseen utilizar para pagar salam añadió
que las tiendas tendrían que Mostrar
claramente el tipo de cambio que
utilizan cada día la unificación de los
distintos tipos de cambio del Líbano es
una de las condiciones previas
establecidas por el fondo monetario
internacional hace casi un año para que
el país se convierta en una economía de
Mercado y así poder acceder a un rescate
de 3.000 millones de dólares para el
final de este segmento Cuál es su cifra
del día pues Ángela falta de una le
tengo dos cifras las utilidades de 2022
de 2 gigantes petroleros suramericanos
primero la brasileña petrobras que
reportó más de 36.000 millones de
dólares y la colombiana ecopetrol que
ganó casi 7.000 millones de dólares
ambas casi que duplicaron su ingreso sus
utilidades y en ambos casos la cifra es
histórica y a qué se debe esto
principalmente a la disparada de precios
del petróleo que generó la guerra en
ucra nia Gracias Daniela y nos vemos más
tarde en una hora exactamente